yeah are you gonna stay in la for a
while yeah for
forever
i'm an la guy for are you
i love l.a i love la too
it is everything that i need those
[ __ ] idiots that moved to texas
those [ __ ] morons some of them were
coming back tim dillon i saw him the
other night he's like i'm moving back
october 1st it's like no [ __ ] they saw
that on the joey diaz podcast yeah they
got to come back well yeah there's
nothing out there i mean it's going to
be fun for three years yeah ellie's the
best
yeah it is you could have the it has the
best food if you could you know where to
go right
it's got you know the beaches the best
weather
the best weather you don't have to
[ __ ] scrape ice off your windshield
to go to work in the morning yeah it's a
little it's expensive i get it but it's
like um
but also la has the thing
that
the weed no this is weed that's kidding
but they have
just by
living here
magic can happen
i'll give you an example
i was gonna do it dude nothing
i was i just needed to adjust my body
i was in a one time i was in
koreatown i was up at a korean
restaurant called
super jeep
and um i was eating with my girlfriend
and this korean guy comes up to me
what did you say the korean guy came up
to me okay would you guess that
i heard something no no a korean guy
came up to me
yeah and he goes
uh hey dude
i'm eating i'm like what's up
hey i like the comedy
great right it'll sound mexican
hey bro let me know i like your comedy i
go thank you and he goes i direct her
and i go oh cool
right
because you want to do music videos
i go i love music videos and i don't
know what it was but it's like i gave
him my
number so a week later
the dude texted me tomorrow music video
if he got a response from you i'm going
to be livid
what yeah did you respond right away
no
no i did
because i he i think he texted me i have
made the video right
he and he said two words
eminem
and he goes dr dorae
and i go what
so he gave me the address i show up next
thing i know i'm in a [ __ ] van
right like a bus
with dr dre and marshall you know eminem
and i'm doing one of our music videos
right so you're in uh one of the videos
it's called
um we made you i think the song is
called is it out yet it was this is
years ago this happened this is back
back in the day
and like
those are so many things like that
happen where i'm like somewhere
right and somebody goes hey you know i
mean this is in l.a you know i mean i'm
doing something like i was back in the
day when i you know so what was the
situation you were eating and this guy
worked at the restaurant no he was just
the guy that was eating there uh he just
walked right up to me he goes you know
music video
that's basically all he said
he was the director of this [ __ ]
eminem video it was crazy and he knew
you from the podcast no you know this is
way before the podcast so he knew me
from mad tv or whatever wow right but
i'm just saying that like things like
that happen where you're just kind of
like yeah i was at a kodak store because
i had one back in the day when you had
to just this is years ago um you'd have
to take these disposable cameras right
and then
i would
use 12 of them and then in six months
i'll go to a codex or to get them
developed i was waiting in line in the
one in beverly center and seth rogen was
behind me in line
and he goes i saw you at the lab factory
can you be in my movie pineapple express
and i go all right you know i mean like
just like little
things that happen just by being here
know i mean so it's like i don't want to
move to austin
because like that doesn't happen like i
can do stand up here yeah you know it's
called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on amazon and
type in stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on amazon and buy
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude